i mean when you're gonna go train for a
for a
ultra or for a triathlete triathlon
you don't train a day and then go do it
you could
it's not gonna work out so good but you
train incrementally
and you look for small slow progress
there's a cumulative
impact of these things
there's two halves to the central
nervous system and they're not actually
haves there's more like
it's it's more like a a 65 35
kind of split between the 65 percent of
your nervous system
is the nervous system that keeps you
functioning
and that is the sympathetic nervous
system that's about 65
plus percent of your nervous system and
it it operates your
body it operates your emotional body and
your mental body so that it can
it can keep your physical body
functioning and a lot of that is
controlled not by your intellect and
your
conscious intelligence but by your
subconscious
and then you have the parasympathetic
nervous system which is the more
contemplative
the more the more sort of discovery
oriented
part of your nervous system that's
looking for
not how to do it the way i've always
done it but how can i do it better
now the parasympathetic nervous system
is very active in children and that's
why children learn
and that's why education is focused on
people before they're at the age of
around 22 years old
doing something on a daily basis
to represent and reactivate your
parasympathetic nervous system
drinking sufficient amount of water
eating food that wasn't produced
in cruelty because
when you eat food that comes through
cruelty such as slaughter
there's a lot of hormones and peptides
and proteins
and lipids in that food
that are going to affect your own
sense of safety and well-being and it's
going to
lock you in so reducing
the amount of fat animal-based
food intake another thing
is be aware of how you're breathing
most people breathe shallow and what's
called paradoxically
and that means that they pull the belly
in when they inhale and that just
inhales into the upper lungs but if you
start
breathing what is a more anatomical way
you'll push the belly out and you'll
breathe down into the lower portion of
your lungs
which will start to activate your
diaphragm which is the largest muscle in
your body
and once that diaphragm is activated
you begin to have a relationship with
two things
your subconscious brain
and your emotional body both of which
are centered around the solar plexus
which is part of that
diaphragmatic complex
that's just the beginning so sit
and breathe diaphragmatically pushing
the belly out on the inhale and in on
the exhale
and do it for three minutes in the
morning three minutes before lunch
three minutes before dinner and three
minutes before bed not a lot of time
total of 12 minutes in a day
drink sufficient amounts of water
the first glass of water could be some
salt water slightly saline water because
that's
a more assimilable kind of
of mixture of chemistry because most of
the water in your body is the same as
the ocean
the same saline content and i'm not
telling you anything that you don't know
because you're an expert on these things
also
and one last piece give yourself
time in the morning
to contemplate your day
and give yourself time in the evening
to contemplate your day
the morning is a dedication
contemplation
and the evening is kind of an analytical
com contemplation
and you will start packaging your day
in between what i'm going to do and how
i might do it
what i did and how i might do it better
at the end of the day
and what's going to happen is you're
going to start programming your sleep
and your waking hours so that you can
work with life
as a tool rather than as a happen
chance we've started a school that
teaches this
there's many ways in which you can find
information about this
all of your podcasts explore
this so i would encourage people
to just do the things that they have
heard
and found to be effective either in your
podcast
through the extension of your podcasts
and however
i appreciate the practicality of those
tools
right they're very simple they're basic
but
a lot of bang for the buck right and
they're not things that are going
to alter your life dramatically after
one day of practicing them there's a
cumulative
impact of these things they become more
powerful
as levers the more that you practice
them
what did you call it when you said i
don't know if we can change the world
in a we may need a revolution what was
that
mm-hmm incremental yeah incrementally
you said that and that's what you're
saying isn't it
i mean when you're going to go train for
a for a
ultra or for a triathlete triathlon
um you don't train a day and then go do
it
no you could it's not going to work out
so good but
you train incrementally and you look for
small
slow progress and that's what i mean by
my 50-year plan
38 years left small slow progress
and if you keep the discipline without
having to
see the results that's an important
element in the practicality of
an opportunity yeah i think that's a
really good point it reminds me of
of something i've said many times before
that i believe in which is
this notion that we
overestimate or over index on things we
think we can accomplish
in a year and we wildly underestimate
what we can accomplish in
a decade and i think if we
can do exactly what you were talking
about which is expand the scope
of this timeline and and and
take a step back from our attachment to
the results and just
be engaged in the process that we will
all be amazed before we're halfway
through
that is so quote the uh sober
literature i love that i love that
[Music]
you